اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل احد اقدم
مستشاريه في سوريا خلال غاره اسرائيليه
صاروخيه في منطقه السيده زينب بريف دمشق
وقال الحرس الثوري في بيان له ان المستشار
ردي موسوي يحمل رتبه لواء وانه كان مسؤول
وحده دعم وحده المقاومه في سوريا وتوعد
الحارس الثوري اسرائيل بانها سوف تدفع ثمن
جريمه الاغتيال حسب تعبيره وقالت وكاله
انباء تسنيم الايرانيه ان رض موسوي كان
مقربا من قاسم سليماني القائد السابق
لفيلق القدس في الحرس الثوري
الايراني وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه ان اسرائيل ستدفع ثمن ما سماها
بالجريمه الارهابيه التي نفذتها في اغتيال
احد مستشاري الحارس الثوري الايراني واضاف
ان الرد على هذه الجريمه سيكون صارما
ومؤثرا وسيتم في الوقت والمكان المناسبين
ولن يوفر المجال لاي استغلالات اسرائيليه
حسب
تعبيره معنا من طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره
عبد القادر فايز عبد القادر كيف تتفاعل
هذه القضيه في ايران حتى
الان ربما نقول هناك تفاعل كبير حقيقه لما
جرى في سوريا يوم امس وهو قيام اسرائيل
باختيال هذا القائد البارز في الوحده
الخارجيه في الحرس ال الور الايراني
والمعروف بجنرال الاسناد كل ما نسمعه هنا
في ضهران كلام المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
كلام الرئيس الايراني الخارجيه الايرانيه
بيان الحرس الثوري وكذلك الصحف والاعلام
الايراني كل هؤلاء يتحدثون بلغه تشي بان
ايران خسرت شخصا وازنا حقيقه عندما نتحدث
عن التموضع العسكري الايراني انطلاقا من
الاراضي السوريه عندما نتحدث ح عن النفوذ
الايراني الاقليمي الذي يقوده الحرس
الثوري بالمعنى العسكري والامني بالدرجه
الاولى وعندما نتحدث عن مشروع ايران في
المنطقه الذي تسميه مشروع المقاومه لذلك
هذا الرجل هو رجل مهم حقيقه خاصه وبانه
كان معنيا بما يعرف باسناد هذه الجبهه
جبهه جنوب لبنان حزب الله حتى وصولا الى
الجبهه الفلسطينيه في غزه وكذلك جبهات
مقاومه اخرى تقول ايران بانها مهمه في
مساحات الاقليم لذلك اليوم حديث ايران على
ان الرد قادم ربما هو لاحتواء كل هذا
الموضوع خاصه وبان ليله امس يمكن ان نقول
بان هناك مجموعه من الايرانيين من الشباب
من الطلاب من العامه حقيقه تظاهروا وسط
ليله امس امام مجلس الامن القومي هنا في
طهران وكانوا يطالبون عبر الشعارات التي
رفعوها بالثار لمقتل هذا الرجل البارز في
الحرس الثوري رضي موسوي لذلك ايران تتحدث
عن رد تتحدث على ان اسرائيل ستدفع الثمن
ولكن هناك كلمه سر حقيقه في حديث المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الذي يقول بان ايران
ستفعل ذلك ولكن دون ان تمنح اسرائيل مساحه
ما اسماها بان تستغل الاوضاع في الاقليم
لماذا هذا الكلام لان ايران لديها قناعه
ان اسرائيل الان تعيش حاله ضغط غير مسبوقه
في تاريخ تشكيل هذه الدوله سواء في الجبهه
الداخليه في الضغط داخل غزه في جنوب لبنان
في البحر الاحمر وباب المندب في البعد
الذي له علاقه بالاعلام وربما السرديه
الاسرائيليه التاريخيه في العالم الغربي
او حتى داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هناك من يعتقد بان دخول مباشر لايران على
الخط حتى ولو كانت للرد على اغتيال هذا
القائد البارز ربما يمنح اسرائيل درجا
للنزول ربما عن هذه الشجره لذلك ما نسمح
الان بان اسرائيل ستدفع الثمن كما تقول
ايران ولكن كيف ومتى واين وما اليات ذلك
هذا غير واضح حقيقه حتى الان شكرا لك عبد
القادر فايز مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا
من طهران